I not think this individualistic culture
is in itself.
Destroying the principles are spiritual
human level of community.
Do you not think that economic
inequality creates in a human being a
sense of injustice,
of unfairness?
Because people.
Do you know what Kandis the 90 percent
of people that are rich?
Do you know why they're rich?
They was born rich because I to tell you
something,
I think that economic disparity creates
that feeling,
but at a fundamental understanding of
economics can tell you that most people
that are rich are born rich.
It's not like there's a tiny minority of
people that are like you that come from
a poor background and managed to
overcome it,
and this is what a pro I problem.
I've noticed we have a lot of great
people is they sort of belief that their
greatness is something that can be
replicated and I don't think it it can.
I see.
So I believe in the individual you
don't.
That's for differences,
but the primary goal of the individual
should be to serve the community.
I,
I do not believe that the primary goal
of what the individual fields.
So you're,
you're just,
you're discounting the human spirit.
He was counting.
Now there is.
Let me ask you a quick no,
there's not in a humanity.
Think of animals in the wild.
Even have to go to humanity.
We can just think about animals in the
wild.
What is our human instinct?
Okay?
Are you going to make sure that everyone
on this block is fed?
Before you feed yourself?
Do you go around and say,
Hey,
have you had breakfast this morning at
breakfast this morning?
Hey,
how are you going to make sure you're
eating?
If you have any of you have an excess,
of course you're going to do the humans.
Human condition in our incentives are
going to be one of the richest.
The 15 people on the planet have got as
much cumulative.
Well first,
the poorest 5 billion,
but your neck.
So no,
no,
no.
Okay,
okay.
Excuse me.
First and foremost,
you're talking about literally point
two,
zero,
zero.
One percent of the world is what he's
talking about and what are they
preaching?
What do they want socialism so that
nobody else has the opportunity to
become what they've become.
They are the ones that are pushing it.
Are you kidding?
George Soros doesn't want socialist
policies.
Jeff Bezos is the richest man in the
world,
doesn't want socialist policies.
They want to make sure that no one else
has the opportunity to get.